entsetzen in frankreich nach der
enthauptung eines lehrers fanden die
ermittler nach einem islamistischen
terrornetzwerk corona in deutschland die
infektionszahlen steigen die kanzlerin
appelliert an die bevölkerung und der
bundespräsident geht in quarantäne und
tennis in köln favorit alexander zverev
schied beim atp turnier ins finale ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag an meiner seite ist
norbert lehmann für den sport ein
sponsor familie frankreichs präsident
spricht von einem bösartigen
islamistischen terroranschlag auf
offener straße wurde ein 47-jähriger
geschichtslehrer enthauptet er hatte im
unterricht über meinungsfreiheit
gesprochen und mohammed karikaturen
gezeigt die grausame attacke gestern
nachmittag hier bei paris in kosovo nur
in der mutmaßliche 18 jährige täter ist
russisch tschetschenischer herkunft
er wurde von der polizei erschossen die
behörden haben neun menschen
festgenommen
an der schule des opfers und in ganz
frankreich herrscht fassungslosigkeit
thomas ley de berichtet eine schule eine
gemeinde ein land sind entsetzt in kos
santorin gedenken schüler eltern und
kollegen heute des getöteten
geschichtslehrer sind seit gestern alle
unter schock und jetzt müssen wir uns
vor allem unsere kinder kümmern denn für
sie ist es besonders schrecklich ich
hatte den lehrer seit zwei jahren er war
sehr freundlich er war einer der wenigen
lehrer die uns helfen
er war ein ausgezeichneter lehrer sehr
engagiert gegenüber seinen schülern mit
viel wohlwollen und respekt für seine
schüler ein 18-jähriger mit
flüchtlingsstatus tötete den lehrer und
veröffentlichte danach bilder in
sozialen medien bevor er von der polizei
erschossen wurde
das opfer hatte im unterricht die
mohammed karikaturen und die
meinungsfreiheit behandelt und war
daraufhin bedroht worden
schulen sind in frankreich die vermittle
republikanischer werte darum trifft der
anschlag an den besonderen nerv noch am
abend traf der präsident am tatort ein
es war kein zufall dass heute abend ein
lehrer von diesem terroristen umgebracht
wurde
denn er wollte die republik und ihre
werte treffen die aufklärung die
möglichkeit aus unseren kindern egal
woher sie kommen
und egal ob sie gläubig sind oder nicht
egal welcher religion sie haben freie
bürger zu machen
vertreter aller parteien verurteilten
die tat gewerkschafter forderten die
werte der republik zu verteidigen
wir sollten eine besondere
unterrichtseinheit zur meinungsfreiheit
haben inklusive der karikaturen
die regierung kündigte eine nationale
gedenkfeier für das opfer an
die franzosen haben schon etliche
furchtbare anschläge erlebt thomas walde
in paris warum trifft dieser das land
noch mal besonders das hat mehrere
gründe zum einen trifft es zum ersten
mal einen lehrer hier in frankreich bei
einem solchen anschlag dann ist da der
besonders barbarische umstand dass er am
helllichten tag auf offener straße
enthauptet wurde
vor seinem arbeitsplatz einer schule und
das ist hier in frankreich ein
besonderer ort das motto der
französischen republik von freiheit
gleichheit brüderlichkeit ist hier in
frankreich an jeder schule zu finden das
ist der ort an dem staatsbürger
herangebildet werden heraus gebildet
werden und darum trifft dieser anschlag
die gesamte nation
und dann ist da der umstand in denen der
staatsanwalt heute noch einmal erinnerte
dass nämlich diese anstalt noch einmal
die besondere terrorgefahr verdeutliche
unter der das land ja schon seit einiger
zeit leidet vor einigen wochen zuletzt
gab es ja auch einen anschlag am
ehemaligen redaktionsgebäude von chania
informationen live aus paris von thomas
walde vielen dank
jetzt corona hierzulande hat die zahl
der neuinfektionen schon wieder einen
höchststand erreicht den dritten tag in
folge
das robert koch institut meldet 7830
neue fälle
der rasante anstieg weckt erinnerungen
an früher aber die absoluten zahlen sind
nur bedingt vergleichbar denn
mittlerweile viel mehr getestet wird
infiziert hat sich auch einen
personenschützer von bundespräsident
steinmeier steinmeier selbst wurde zwar
negativ getestet bleibt aber vorsorglich
in quarantäne und die bundeskanzlerin
appelliert in ihrem wöchentlichen
video-podcast eindringlich wie der
winter wird wie unser weihnachten wird
das entscheidet sich in diesen kommenden
tagen das entscheiden wir alle durch
unser handeln
klaus brodbeck berichtet das virus
verbreitet sich immer weiter ganz ohne
rücksicht auf protokoll und prominenz
der bundespräsident hat sich freiwillig
in quarantäne begeben nachdem bei einem
seiner personenschützer corona
festgestellt worden war
ein erster test steinmeiers fiel negativ
aus das ist die gute nachricht
mit der schlechten tritt am nachmittag
winfried kretschmann vor die presse
baden württemberg verschärft die korona
vorschriften ab montag
die entwicklung dort wie vielerorts im
land stündlich kommen welche dazu so
dass wir in bälde ein rotes gebiet sein
werden und das zeigt es ist eben
alarmstufe rot wo es nicht so wehtut
verschärfen wir jetzt damit wir kitas
schulen und den arbeitsplatz von
weiteren maßnahmen möglichst frei halten
können
die kanzlerin nutzt ihren wöchentlichen
podcast für einen appel
ich bitte sie verzichten sie auf jede
reise die nicht wirklich zwingend
notwendig ist
auf jede feier die nicht wirklich
zwingend notwendig ist
bitte bleiben sie wenn immer möglich zu
hause an ihrem wohnort von der
ostseeküste kommen gegensätzliche
signale
mecklenburg vorpommern lockert ab
kommenden mittwoch die bestimmungen für
das vielkritisierte beherbergungs verbot
für das inland sehen wir das in den
risikogebieten jetzt einschränkungen
herrschen
und deshalb können wir für die
risikogebiete im inland zukünftig auf
die quarantäne und den zweiten test
verzichten aber das sage ich ganz
deutlich nicht auf den ersten kontakte
einschränken zu hause bleiben möglichst
nicht reisen
zugleich erleichterungen genau dafür in
zwölf bundesländern
es bleibt verwirrend ob ihre appelle
fruchten kann sich die kanzlerin direkt
vor ihrer tür anschauen vier berliner
bezirke gehören zu den deutschen corona
hot spots zum teil mit über 100 neue
infektionen auf 100.000 einwohner
lisa jahren die über die stimmung in der
hauptstadt wochenmarkt in
berlin-charlottenburg eine masken
pflicht gibt es hier nicht doch die
meisten tragen sie trotzdem jeden tag
neue höchstwerte neue appelle neue
regeln was macht das mit den berliner
also ob man sich noch mit freunden
trifft oder nicht kann nicht monatelang
so ein hohes level der sorge und angst
haben also ich glaube dass irgendwann
fahren den menschen so ein bisschen
runter einfach um uns gesund zu halten
und das merke ich bei mir auch dieses
blöde masken tragen ist gerade für
brückenträger oft unangenehm weil
bestätigt aber wenn wir es damit
hinkriegen hallo die sperrstunde in
berlin sollte auch so eine maßnahme sein
um corona einzudämmen
letzte woche eingeführt gestern in
teilen gekippt denn elf wirte hatten
geklagt auch mike stolz von der bar zum
schmutzigen hobby es ist doch keine
maßnahme bars um 23 uhr zu schließen
nur weil man illegale partys in parks in
wohnung verhindern geht es macht diesen
stand jetzt nur die elf bars der kläger
dürfen länger als 23 uhr öffnen
aber nach elf keinen alkohol mehr
ausschenken ist perfekt die sperrstunde
wird nun noch in der nächsten
gerichtlichen instanz verhandelt
polizei und ordnungsamt kontrollieren
unterdessen immer wieder so auch in
dieser nacht im chor ohne hotspot berlin
neukölln
nicht nur deutschland viele länder in
europa verschaffen ihre corona regeln in
london etwa dürfen sich menschen die in
getrennten haushalten leben nur noch
draußen treffen in polen schließen
vielerorts schwimmbäder und fitness
studio und in den prager messehallen
richtet die tschechische armee ein
provisorisches krankenhaus ein
das land registrierte erstmals mehr als
11.000 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages auch in österreich beklagen die
behörden rasant steigende
infektionszahlen die situation laufe
völlig aus dem ruder warnt etwa die
landesregierung in salzburg und zieht
konsequenzen
seit heute steht die gemeinde kochel mit
ihren rund 7000 einwohnern komplett
unter quarantäne
bis auf wenige ausnahmen dafür keiner
rein oder raus peter hilbert berichtet
durchfahren ist erlaubt anhalten nicht
das machen die polizisten hier klar
kugel in österreich steht unter
quarantäne
viele kehren
in den ort nahe der deutschen grenze
darf nun kein ortsfremder mehrere walter
kogler bin wo er im betrieb kuchen der
von dir eine kugel hat zu viele
infektionen ohne klaren infektionsherd
im rund 7000 einwohner ort sind bisher
115 positiv tendenz stark steigend
wieder müssen gasthäuser schließen in
österreich ist kuchl der erste ort der
das zum zweiten mal erleben dass im
gasthof mühlthaler entlässt wird fritz
sei weit nun auch die letzten saison
kräfte nach kugel kommt keiner mehr
es ist alles studiert bis ostern mit dem
lockdown das gibt uns jetzt den letzten
rest wahrscheinlich was der gesundheit
dient bringt hier unternehmen in nöte
also sieht er grundsätzliche
katastrophen muss man sagen weil wir so
um 70 prozent unserer mitarbeiter kommen
von außerhalb von kuchl und die können
jetzt und dürfen nicht zum arbeitsplatz
erscheinen was kuchl erlebt will
österreich vermeiden
überall werden maßnahmen verschärft
regional unterschiedlich in
oberösterreich eine
registrierungspflicht in der gastronomie
in tirol homeschooling ab klasse 9
doch die infektionszahlen steigen weiter
vor allem in städten und so hat die
österreichische regierung angekündigt am
montag weitere verschärfungen für das
ganze land zu beschließen
ein großes problem in der korona krise
sind größere feiern wenn sie zu so
genannten virus clustern werden wenn
sich also an einem ort sehr schnell sehr
viele menschen anstecken wie diese
infektionsketten entstehen können sie
sich in unserer zdf heute app anschauen
in neuseeland hat premier ministerin
jazz in the dawn überraschend deutlich
die parlamentswahl gewonnen hatte
erreichte mit ihrer labour partei die
absolute mehrheit und ist somit nicht
mehr auf koalitionspartner angewiesen
die 40 jährige hat unter anderem mit
ihrem erfolgreichen kampf gegen korona
punkten können nach einem strengen
lockdown gibt es in neuseeland
mittlerweile kaum mehr neuinfektionen im
konflikt um die kaukasusregion berg
karabach gehen die kämpfe zwischen armee
linien und aserbaidschan weiter bei
einem raketenangriff in der
aserbaidschanischen stadt gaza wurden
laut behörden 13 menschen getötet mehr
als 50 wurden verletzt
die einigung auf eine waffenruhe
vergangene woche soll von beiden
parteien mehrfach gebrochen worden seien
ganz anderes thema jetzt die suche nach
einem atomendlager in deutschland daran
können sich ab heute auch bürger
beteiligen
hierzulande sind 1900 solcher
transportbehälter mit hoch radioaktivem
material zwischengelagert der atommüll
soll ab 2050 unterirdisch eingelagert
werden
dafür eignen sich nach staatlichen
gutachten grundsätzlich 54 prozent der
landesfläche beziehungsweise 90 regionen
bei einer virtuellen konferenz können
sich jetzt erstmals anwohner zu wort
melden oliver deuker berichtet kassel
fachkonferenz vor leeren rängen wegen
der korona pandemie christian schröder
wäre gern gekommen er wohnt bei
waddekath in sachsen-anhalt einem der
genannten teilgebiete für ein mögliches
endlager die eignung des salzstocks hier
bezweifelte er trotzdem steht er
grundsätzlich zu dem eingeschlagenen weg
bei der endlagersuche ich glaube dass
der prozess jetzt auch eine faire chance
verdient hat
ich möchte aber auch dass das ist einmal
die fehler die in der vergangenheit
passiert sind in gorleben dann auch
nicht wiederholt werden
da setzen wir darauf wir werden das
kritisch begleiten auf jeden fall und
auch ja sagen was uns nicht passt
auch das bayerische turm anz bank mit
den dortigen granitvorkommen ist in der
auswahl eines möglichen endlager
standortes sehr zum ärger von
bürgermeister martin behringer die
versprochene transparenz und
öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung beim
auswahlprozess für ihn nur leere worte
unser gebiet ist 37.000 quadratkilometer
groß wir sollten daran ständige
transparente bürgerbefragung oder auch
der bürger mit einbeziehen also diese
bürgerforen die wo er zur stattfinden
sollten das ist für mich ein ding der
unmöglichkeit der veranstalter der
digitalen fachkonferenz und oberster
wächter des verfahrens tritt den
vorwürfen entgegen denn im nächsten
schritt konkretere standorte in die
betrachtung kommen werden ehren diesen
orten bürgerbüros eingerichtet das
werden unterstützungsleistungen form
auch von möglichkeiten eigene expertise
einzukaufen bereitgestellt also genau
das was von den bürgerinitiativen
gefordert wird dies im gesetz angelegt
ob das die menschen in den betroffenen
regionen überzeugen wird 2031 soll ein
endlager gefunden sein 2050 die
einlagerung beginnen jetzt spart man
aber du hast englischen fußball wird ja
das spitzenspiel der premier league
und das war auch echter spitzenfußball
der tabellen erste everton gegen den
tabellenzweiten liverpool jürgen klopp
und seine reds führten zweimal in diesem
intensiven stadt-derby am ende ein
unentschieden 2 2
jürgen klopps team dabei näher dran am
sieg liverpool liegt gleich nach gut
zwei minuten vor durch money hat danach
aber pech abwehrspieler virtual van dyk
muss nach dieser attacke verletzt vom
platz
liverpool verliert kurz die ordnung so
kommt everton zum ausgleich michael
kiehn mit dem kopf eins zu eins nach der
pause muss alle zum 2 1 für die reds
aber auch dieses mal kontakt erwarten
die 81 minute schelbert lu in zum 22 der
vermeintliche siegtreffer von liverpools
henderson in der nachspielzeit fällt
nicht wegen abseits eine
millimeterentscheidung so bleibt
erwarten auf im fünften ligaspiel
ungeschlagen tabellenführer gefolgt vom
stadt rivalen liverpool
ja und bei uns in der fußball-bundesliga
hat rb leipzig die tabellenführung
durch einen sieg in augsburg hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse des vierten
spieltags bislang vier auswärts siege
und ein unentschieden
augsburg verliert wie gesagt gegen
leipzig nur zu zwei hoffenheim
unterliegt dortmund 0 2 1 freiburg und
bremen trennen sich unentschieden 1 1
hertha verliert zu hause gegen stuttgart
mit 0 2 und mainz muss ich leverkusen
geschlagen geben 0 zu 1 heute zwei
abendspiele bielefeld gegen bayern und
gladbach gegen wolfsburg die tabelle
hinter spitzenreiter leipzig jetzt der
bvb auf platz zwei dahinter punktgleich
stuttgart frankfurt augsburg und bremen
die bayern siebter können aber mit einem
sieg in bielefeld heute abend auf platz
zwei vorrücken
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
freiburg ja unter am tabellenende alles
unverändert köln mainz und schalke
die beiden abendspiele ausführlich bei
uns zu sehen im aktuellen sportstudio um
23 uhr zu gast bei jochen breyer
bvb geschäftsführer hans joachim watzke
alexanders wäre steht im finale des
atp-turniers in köln deutschlands bester
tennisspieler besiegte den spanier
alejandro davidovitch china in zwei
engen sätzen mit 7 5 und 7 zu 6 211
sieht wie der sichere sieger aus als er
mit seinem zehnten ass auf 4 zu 1 im
zweiten satz davon zieht zwischen faust
ballen und kopfschütteln liegen jedoch
beim turnier favoriten oft nur wenige
sekunden alle hände oder vidovic von
china der zwei jahre jüngere spanier
gibt sich nicht geschlagen stoppbälle
sind sein markenzeichen zverev muss ans
netz und wirkte nicht immer sicher
matchball abgewehrt es kommt zum
tie-break in dem zverev nun wieder
konzentrierter spielt 7 zu 3 für ihn ein
hart umkämpfter einzug ins finale von
köln
da spielt dann morgen gegen den kanadier
felix schiller alias da drücken wir
natürlich die daumen ich finde es mal am
schönsten wenn die sich nach so einem
spiel dann doch wieder so
freundschaftlich über abschieden oder
ein bisschen was am schluss dieser
sendung fürs herz der sonntag wird trüb
und bringt wenig sonne aber nächste
woche wird es zumindest nackig milder
mehr zum wetter hat gleich katja hornuf
claus kleber freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um viertel vor elf und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind danke für ihr interesse
machen sie sich noch einen schönen
samstagabend und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren ein
kleines tief zieht hier von schweden
weiter in richtung finnland seine kalte
und beschäftigt uns heute nacht und
morgen dann auch noch den nordosten
deutschlands
das hoch über frankreich bringt etwas
sonnenschein auch in den oberrhein
noch interessanter ist aber vielleicht
das tief über dem atlantik denn das
schaufeln in den nächsten tagen von
südwesten über spanien und portugal und
frankreich die wärme zu uns nach
mitteleuropa und dann müssen die
kühleren temperaturen nach nordosteuropa
ausweichen
heute nacht also fährt erst mal ein
bisschen regen an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee sonst ist es locker bewölkt
es bindet sich auch mal nebel
die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 9 grad an der nordsee und 1
grad hier im westerzgebirge und morgen
steigen die werte dann auf 7 grad in den
mittelgebirgen bis auf 13 grad am
oberrhein am niederrhein
für viele bleibt das morgen wieder ein
trüber tag die kaltfront zieht ein
bisschen weiter nach süden so kann es
zwischen hannover und berlin mal etwas
regnen
im norden dagegen zeigt sich häufiger
die sonne bei nordwestwind und auch im
südwesten werden sie mal die sonne sehen
können in den nächsten tagen wird es
dann sukzessive wärmer am mittwoch
steigen die werte auf 14 bis 20 grad
schönes wochenende